If you want to make a drop-down list like this or Drop
Down Menu on Google, stay with me and I will tell you
the way because Google has made many updates recently
on Google DAX. Let's go. For example,
I have now opened a Google Sheet file, as you can see.
This file is in it. If you would like, by the way, I will share it
with you.  In the comments below, while I am here,
I want to specify the type of Task this is, so I click on, and from
here it shows me the names of the people of the recent meetings that I
have. Also, if I write the name of a file I have, a PDF, for example, it will show me the things that are on my Google Drive.
If I want to make roundabouts, and I choose
this type, for example, it will be Yo.  XDi, and from here,
choose the color, and here I chose if I want to show a
mistake for me if I put another need, click on it and I can stay with me and
choose and if I went down under
that, it remains apparent to me in
even if they are interested.  Your work,
write to me below in the comments, I will see you in a
new video